Hello world.
It's a Raj and just a few days ago,
Facebook's AI research team
released a demo called dense posts.
They were able to map out every single
pixel of a human body in a given video
and not just for a single human, but
for many, many humans all at once,
even more impressive.
They were able to do this in videos with
lots of distractions and general chaos
on a single GPU. Splost.
Nope, just deep learning.
This is pretty cool and has tons of
applications and we're going to learn how
they did it in this video.
Creating d animated
characters is a lot of work.
The tools to do so are expensive and
require teams of people working for months
on end.
Big Production Studios with the available
budgets are able to track humans and
convert them to animations,
but for people without big budgets,
this technology will
democratize that ability.
Remember my video on the
deep fakes algorithm? Well,
this can be used for a full body version
of that. If we can track a human,
we can swap out their entire
body with a different one.
Lending to some surreal scenarios like
Geoff Hinton charging into more door
instead of Aragorn augmented
reality applications could
use this to label people
that you see in real time with all sorts
of statistics and it would give away
for machines to be able to better read
our body language for everything from
sentiment analysis to full body
tracking to virtual reality gaming.
This is the new state of the
art in human pose estimation.
And to understand how it works,
we're going to have to try
and work through the thought
process the authors had
both in terms of building on previous
discoveries and trying different methods.
So let's say we have a
video of a human dancing.
This is a two dimensional grid of pixels,
but when you or I look at it,
we're able to tell that there are
indeed three d objects that are being
represented by this two d grid.
We want our computer to have this
ability as well and in a way that we can
visualize it.
Meaning we'll want to transform this
tutti human into a three d model.
Once we have that three d model,
we can do whatever we want with it,
put it into any sort of scene,
swap it with another three d model,
change its features,
lots of possibilities,
but all of these possibilities depend
on us being able to construct a three
model of this human in real time that
updates its movements as the human moves.
When want to construct a correspondence,
this is a computer vision term that is a
measure of how well pixels in one image
correspond to pixels in another image.
In our case it would be a two D to three
d image and we don't want any holes in
our image. We want all the pixels
to be as close together as possible,
so we'll call it a dense correspondence
and we'll just focus on doing this for
humans.
For now to create a dense correspondence
will need to perform some object
detection,
object segmentation and pose estimation.
That's a multilevel problems,
so we want to start with a method
that's as simple as possible.
We got so many different
avenues to go about this,
but ideally we could use some sort of
labeled data set because having a label
just makes training machine learning
algorithms much easier since it just
involves learning a function
that represents the mapping
between the input data
and the labels.
In this case,
what would the ideal
labeled datasets look like?
There are tons of labeled image
data sets out there these days.
Pascal Cfr,
image net.
These are basically big collections of
images of a variety of random objects
each with their own particular label.
These datasets have been a catalyst for
all of the recent progress in computer
vision algorithms,
but we don't want to just label a human.
If we see one in a video, we want to be
able to create a three d model of one.
There's not really a Dataset of human
images with the label being the three d
model,
so we'd have to create one ourselves
and it would involve humans manually
creating annotations that relates
three d images to surface spaced
representations of the human body,
and that's exactly what they did.
They basically asked the annotators to
annotate regions corresponding to defined
body parts like the head and the legs.
All of these annotations were labeled with
their corresponding three d body part,
which acted as the label.
They did this for 50 k humans,
which summed up to be a total of 5 million
manually annotated correspondences.
Once we have our Dataset, we're going to
have to decide on what model to built.
We know that deep learning is the
state of the art when it comes to
classification and that convolutional
networks are the state of the art in image
classification, but it's not just
classification we're trying to do,
but regression as well. What's the
next move the human is going to make?
The next question would be,
has anyone done something similar
with a convolutional network?
Of course.
Luckily there was a recent architecture
called dense Raj that did this for all
sorts of objects and got decent results,
so we could start with that architecture.
In the first step, the network,
we'll classify a pixel as belonging to
either the background or one of several
region parts that gives a rough
estimate of surface coordinates.
This is essentially a labeling task that
can be trained using gradient descent.
In the second step,
a regression model will indicate the
exact coordinates of the pixel within the
region part.
A more formal way of saying this is
that in the first stage they will assign
position l two the body parts c that has
the highest likelihood as calculated by
the classification branch and in the
second stage it will use the regressor to
place the point l in the
continuous coordinate pair UV.
That is a parameterization of
part c c can take 25 values.
One would be the background,
meaning that P is a 25 way classification
unit and we can train 24 regression
functions are each of which provides
two d coordinates within its respective
parts. Both the classification
and regression tasks are
trained by minimizing a
respective loss function,
but the regression loss is only taken
into account for a part if the pixel is
within the specific part.
So our network can work,
but it requires a lot of tasks for a
single network like parts segmentation and
pixel localization. They use a
technique called region of interest.
Pooling to create different
regions and fed the results,
seeing features into
regions specific branches.
This decompose the complexity of
the task into controllable modules,
all of which which could be trained
jointly in an end to end approach.
So it's a fully convolutional network on
top of region of interest pooling that
is entirely devoted to two tasks,
generating a classification and regression
head that provide part assignment and
park coordinate predictions
to improve the model.
They used a technique called cascading
meaning using a collection of models
using all the information collected from
the output of one model as additional
information for the next
classifier in the cascade.
The output of the region of interest
align module feeds into the dense network
as well as networks for the
masking and key points tasks.
The first stage predictions from all
tasks are then combined and fed into a
second stage refinement units of each
branch when experimenting on novel videos.
There architecture worked well across
the board for not just one human but
multiple humans.
Unfortunately they haven't released
the initial source code just yet,
but we can recreate what they did
using the details in the paper. Also,
the Dataset they created is open source.
So definitely check that out.
Three things to remember from this video.
Dense pose is a new deep learning model
that can estimate three d models of
multiple humans from just
a video on a single GPU.
They use a collection of convolutional
networks to do this performing
classification for assignment and
regression for coordinate to predictions.
And they open sourced the data set
they created mapping humans to their
corresponding three d models. Please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now, I've got to make a good
bipolar, so thanks for watching.